ich hab dich lieb etwas glaubt man jetzt
willkommen beim neuen video
ihr kennt mich an ich bin alex o ich
gehe eigentlich schon ab und zu mal mit
dem trend mit und versuchten auch was
gutes zum trendthema beizutragen und für
den heutigen video reviews ganz
spezielles über die beute wird echt mega
kracher kennt wahrscheinlich alle diese
videos 1000 gradmesser schlosses keine
ahnung april versus iphone 7 + x3 mit
5000 grad ninja schwert gegen computer
mac wohl keine ahnung so eine scheiße
gibt's hier alles auf youtube schon und
ich bin einfach mal hingegangen und hat
mir du musst irgendwas noch kasse machen
und irgendwas was wirklich silber und da
kam mir so vor drei vier tagen die idee
kommen macht doch einfach mal das ganze
mit dem hammer ist ich hab mir so ein
hammer gekauft und ich würde sagen
diesen hammer bringen wir jetzt gleich
auf 1000 grad wir machen nicht wundert
grad die macht nicht 200 grad wir machen
nicht 300 grad wir machen nicht 800 grad
wir machen
1000 grad und um diesen metall hat zu
erhitzen habe ich mir zwei richtig
richtig starke bunsenbrenner geholt
kennst du dass das in diese teile womit
man das erhitzte
ich will gar nicht lange lagern wir
haben krasse sachen die wir gleich gegen
diesen hammer testen werden wer so
gewinnt wer heißer ist wer besser ja ich
würde sagen lasst uns mal kurz den
hammer ist so labil war das wird echt
richtig krank
hier macht man mit der mit der bruder
wollte ich machen beiden blick
alter gibt dir das mal tiefe wasser
keine flamme herauskommt
der hat jetzt locker schon absolut grad
wenn ich mal sagen hier funktioniert
irgendwie nicht glaubt ihr habe ich im
laden fahrrad auf jeden fall nehme ich
dann den hier nur vor alter siehst
wieder glüht siehst du das heftig
das sieht man jetzt wahrscheinlich im
licht nicht so krass aber der glut
extrem leute macht so was auf keinen
fall zu hause nahm
das kann halt auch schnell ins auge ich
kann mich damit aus ich hab die
jahrelange berufserfahrung dem machen
was mit kurzen ja das sind 1000 grad
okay man sieht 1000 grad ich würde sagen
wir fangen erst mal mit pick ups schon
bis bereits gespannt was passiert
ok alter hast du das gesehen
krass oder herr peek at ist jetzt
zusammen gelöscht ich glaube der tisch
ist etwas kaputt hier dass warentest
kassen okay leute ich würde sagen wir
machen weiter mit einem joghurt mal
gucken ob der gegen den 1000 grad im
haushalt ich habe keine wirklich zu
übernehmen als ich meinen dein jack
hause wenn sie an toni an lassen
ja dann geh mal kurz raus und schnell
die kamera auf die dinge schon immer
meine jacke auf mich immer noch weil ich
drei schneller schneller
alter habt ihr das gesehen
[Musik]
boah das war richtig
das müsst ihr euch vergeben er ist
einfach kaputt gegangen guck mal kasse
okay wir haben natürlich noch mehr
sachen zum beispiel meine alte tastatur
bist du bereit meinte der 1000 läufer
man macht das mit die rodeo
[Musik]
ich glaube schon machte tisch noch heile
krass guck mal
man sieht hier richtig die brandfläche
das qualmt heftig ne geile ich würde
sagen machen weiter mit beim schoko
nikolaus keinen sinn er sich dann auch
noch lukas oder nein
ich sag mal so bei 12 tagen war bei
15.000 leid kommt das war noch eine
folge okay aber jetzt kommen wir erst
mal zum absoluten höhepunkt beispiel
sich klebe ich habe mir gedacht wird
völlig zerstört leute ich hab mir
gedacht das ist 100.000 play button
den hat jeder ich würde locker sagen
dann gibt es auf youtube oder den haben
schon bestimmt 10.000 youtuber ich habe
mir gedacht komm das ist nichts
besonderes so upgrade zum beispiel
wollte auch seinen play button zerstören
auch wenn es im endeffekt natürlich
nicht gemacht hat
das ganze video war eigentlich kopiert
von k s sei aber gut aber ich bin nicht
so einer wenn ich das sage dann mache
ich so auch ich meine wer hat den
wissenden kaputten 100.000 play warten
sagt man wer hat das und ich mein ich
hab doch weil er eine million abonnenten
somit habe ich dann einen größeren ich
könnte noch genügend biss haben es ist
natürlich eine starke erinnerung die
jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen kaputt
geht aber ich meine es immer noch da und
ich stehe halt einfach kaputt in mein
zimmer ist doch einzigartig
warum leuchten jetzt bitte die glocken
ich hab dich lieb
scheiße das ist gerade echten trauriger
moment für mich okay bist du bereit
ich will gar nicht mach die augen zu ok
und auch richter klar
aber jetzt hast du einen ohne scheidung
sollte mal ganz ehrlich leute mal ganz
ehrlich wer hat bitte so ein play button
niemanden ich sag mal so bei 100000
likes zerstört dann auch mein eine
million play button mit einer axt die
heftig glüht 100000 likes sind drin ich
hoffe euch das video gefallen
ich finde es mega krass was so ein
glühender 1000 grad hammer alles kann
und wir sehen uns morgen wieder
ich hoffe ihr hattet alle den
wunderbaren rutsch ins neue jahr ich
wünsche euch alles gute für das jahr
2017 und sollte das video war natürlich
eine komplette parodie auf dieses ganze
1000 grad hammer blablabla lebens wird
oma ich hoffe ihr von uns lustig ein
bisschen und wir sehen uns wie gesagt
übermorgen sechs captured und instagram
ab auf jeden fall folgt mit rein und ich
hoffe natürlich ich schaffe jetzt
wirklich schon auf die eine million
stellen wir vor schafft man keine eine
millionen abonnenten ein krieger gar
keine neuen play button
wenn natürlich blöd also leute strengt
euch an